today we're doing something different
today we're talking about someone
in a positive light yay
first time on this channel keanu reeves
everyone
internet's new favorite character
everyone's favorite badass good guy
i know i know it's i've done a lot of
videos but i've been digging a little
deeper into keanu reeves and it's
some pretty fascinating fun stuff that
we can go through together let's go
i'm sure you've already seen the
abundance of memes that happened during
the past couple days
keanu has taken over the internet but
what makes keanu so likable
why does everyone love this guy number
one tiano always knows
what to say in any situation kiana will
have the perfect answer
what is your secret for always staying
down to earth
well i mean gravity
i like how he laughs at his own joke too
what do you think happens when we die
keanu reeves
i know that the ones who love us will
miss us
john wick chapter three so good
so how does he get this wisdom well of
course keanu reeves
number two reason why he's so likable he
is immortal
everyone knows this it's just an
indisputable fact at this point look at
this porsche this is
early 1500s portrait of a man
what do you think
what is this that's going on yeah what
is that
it's a gangster it's a gangster like
what is he trying
to get a lot of weird finger things you
tell us keanu it's literally you
we have a likeness in the eyes yeah and
the mustache and the beard and the
cheekbones and everything
yeah we have the same forehead-ish
eyebrow i think
it's yummy i think there's a website
called keanu
reeves is immortal.com there it is
calories is immortal.com here it is he
doesn't age here's the proof
the website has been updated 2077
still has an age even here how old is he
he's over 50
and the paparazzi referred to him as
young man
mr reese right here young man
that's right young man i know you turned
50 last month and happy birthday but i
it's hard to believe looking at you
maybe i'm getting older or you're
just very very youthful but you i would
never
he doesn't age number three keanu has
a very sad past sad keanu was a meme
that appeared a few years ago
before meme review was a thing what
there were memes before
meme review what the freak this was in
the era of memes where
people just found a picture they thought
was funny and everyone just photoshopped
it that was literally it
i look how many oh look how sad he is
next to said panda
legends say that keanu is still sitting
and still sad
sipping that g fuel when i was digging
in
on the web about you i came across this
and i was web digging about you i found
this phenomenon the sad keanu
oh gosh yeah it was a couple years ago
yeah phenomenon um
where people are taking a photo of you
sitting on a bench eating a sandwich
looking a little bit sad and it became
like this crazy thing on the internet i
mean what do you think about sort of
media attention
um yeah i don't know i didn't think of
that as
media attention um
uh it was funny
that so many people were worried about
your welfare um no i think that's lovely
but uh oh oh the i think it was people
started to do funny things with that
um sad keanu obviously inside account
kiana was a meme or whatever but
it does work in a way because keanu does
have a sad past
there's this clip on facebook that has a
hundred million views
talking about keanu's sad past
[Music]
so apparently keanu was born in lebanon
okay how many people watch me from
lebanon
and his father is half hawaiian and his
name
keanu means cool breeze on a mountain i
don't know
if that's true but that's what he says
tianu is such an exotic name but that is
your real name yes sir that is my name
yes
and what does it mean now is it from
hawaii yes it's a hawaiian name and it
means cool breeze over the mountains
remind me of anything yeah is there
anything about this guy that isn't cool
god damn it so keanu he's clearly
suffered through a lot
it's almost like people fetishize his
past in a way like oh he's been through
so much and
a lot of it is kind of exaggerated as
well but i think what's
important is that yes he's gone through
a lot but
he hasn't let that define him or destroy
him and that's what
is impressive about it number four am i
counting correctly
his love okay i looked into his
interviews
and i found this clip and it's so
bizarre
but sandra bullocka she uh so that was
her first big break with you
yeah and i asked her because everybody
had a crush on you
if she had a crush on you then and this
is what she said
i think about how sweet keanu reeves was
and how
handsome he was he was so hard it was
really it was hard for me to like really
be serious
like he would look at me and i'd be like
did you date him never dated him really
there was just something about me in it
i guess he did
that's not true i think it's true no he
never he was probably intimidated not at
all yeah there's nothing to intimidate
right that's i'm not that
yes you are but we but i think we're
probably friends for that long because
we didn't
yeah right
um is that how you do it that's how i do
it maybe that's why he didn't want to be
with you
and then he's reacting to that clip look
how happy he is
did you did you obviously didn't know i
had a crush on her
oh wow i can't believe you both had
crushes on each
other and you you were so scared we were
working
well i know but there's haven't you ever
had a romance with somebody that you did
a movie with
um
like yes i mean make that face
whether it's whether it's before or
after i mean you can wait until it's
sure
yeah but that's so that so that
chemistry was real because you all
really did
both have feelings like that yeah
it was it was nice yeah yeah yeah and
i mean she's so what's such a wonderful
person sandy come on out
look at this she tricks him and he's
like oh no
is she actually i don't want to look no
no
she's not here but oh god damn you
outland
don't do my man keanu like this that
would have been so great
it would have been really nice no i
believe she's in a relationship now you
the
the window closed you you you had a
chance
you rest assured sandra bullock's
husband is sweating
profusely right now john wick is coming
for you
yeah and then i looked into martia
showing me this
the interview with him talking about
sandra's brother shot this film
and it's so sweet she has a nice nice
such a wonderful um energy about her and
her
and life and she's just wherever she
goes i mean she really gives and wants
things to be
springtime so i don't know i i've
enjoyed her company immensely
oh and she's a really great actress too
no she is no but she is i mean she's
you know again i mean the thing that's
cool about this film i mean it's cast
really very well and the actors are
really good and um you know
she's she's brought a a very uh
you know she's been fighting the the the
this the direction of just being like
you know the
complete damsel in the stress
and moving and okay for a moment
nice how did you not make a move on her
keanu
jesus christ
my god well all of this the sad past
and the non-happening romance this is
what led keanu
into just becoming such a goddamn badass
when keanu acts as john wick he is john
wick okay
in every single film he is john wick the
matrix
training for john wick that love story
movie he's still john wick okay he's
gotta
he's clearly such a badass and have such
intense respect for his craft
gotta reach really well oh that's funny
you can tell keanu really cares about
giving you an experience that is special
in the film and actually putting the
work and effort
into making that happen he does all the
action
himself or at least as much as he can i
love movies
gosh i love movies
i love watching them and i love making
them
uh and this brings up to the number five
which is keanu and money
there's this question your movies have
made so much money
three and a half billion dollars
entertain entertain right yes
that's right that's right everyone is so
obsessed with money
apparently it was reported that he
donated 80 million of his 114 million
earnings
from the matrix sequels i looked around
it
doesn't seem like it's 100 true but he
definitely
is a very giving person he has donated a
lot a lot of money
and he has also said himself that money
doesn't mean anything to me
i made a lot of money but i want to
enjoy life and not stress myself
building my bank account i give lots
away and live simply mostly out of a
suitcase in hotels we all know that good
health is much more important and i
think that is an important distinction
of how you
look at the world and how you look at
money and i and i really really respect
that
then coming to number five the point
number five is keanu reeves in public
when he did the matrix it became such a
smash hit
success that people were obsessed with
this film
inevitably keanu reeves who is the main
star of the film
i found this quote in an interview where
he talks about the matrix becoming
a cult hit and he says he was asked
about the film and it was a surprise
that it became big and he says yes
somewhat i want to make something clear
i am not jesus
i am also no prophet or lone fighter
that will save the world
i find it frightening how many people
believe that being acquainted with me
would solve their personal problems
that's simply not so
but i'm participating in the next two
matrix films with enthusiasm
i don't know if he's joking or not or if
that this is how
his life was actually changed that
people looked at up to him as some
messiah
i could be reading into this wrong but
it is interesting
with keanu and and the public you know
there was this viral clip of him
being in the subway
by the way you're not slick when you're
sitting there with your camera like
this is this is how you look like by the
way
like oh my god he's just like
us he clearly just want to live his life
like everyone else and
i i can't relate to that in a lot of
ways
but when you're that famous this is
inevitable that paparazzi
and living in l.a you get recognized
look how hidden he is we will still find
him
look how many cameras
you know that moment when your bike
doesn't start it's a bit frustrating
imagine being that situation
with a dozen cameras pointing at you
[Laughter]
and some guy across the street choke it
you need to choke them
back yes like okay got it
god what an awful situation like if you
don't get the bike running what do you
do
you're just gonna be stuck there with
all the cameras this is my nightmare
all right here we go oh yeah
who was that that was john wick he's
also very nice with fans which i do
appreciate
taking selfies
please you're one of my favorite doubt
imagine you're flying across the country
you're tired you just want to go home
and then you're met with please you're
one of my favorites
which leads me to the final point
stop asking keanu reeves for pictures
okay
i'm sure listen i want to speak for him
i'm sure he doesn't mind
but i feel like i'm speaking through
keanu he just want to live normally and
not be stopped every moment okay
this is what keanu reeves wants okay
anyhow
after this video went viral where he
says you're breathtaking
the guy that yelled your breath taken
from the audience was offered
uh the game to get it early and he said
no
thank you i would rather if you donate
to charity instead
so in the spirit of keanu reeves and
making this video i wanted to donate all
the profit that this video makes
to the leukemia research foundation it's
where keanu donated a lot of money
because his sister
went through leukemia she survived uh it
took my grandad
and i thought that could be a nice
ending to it and have a nice keanu
effect
of doing something good i know everyone
wants oh keanu reeves he should be
hosting me review or whatever that's not
why i made this video
i'm genuinely just fascinated by the
guys so it doesn't matter
okay that's it bye what you never played
two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price